>> Okay. So I work for the Research Discovery
and Innovation, formerly office of Research
and Discovery, formerly the office for
the senior Vice President of Research.
[Laughter] Started out as an opera singer.
I did that for 15 years.
Well I'm still doing it.
And it's only been in the last three years
where I've started to do musical theater.
[ Singing ]
So this is Elf'd, a production, and
it is based on the Will Farrell movie.
And but the Gaslight tradition is we take
something in the popular culture or you know,
just classic stories and then
we turn them into melodrama.
And I play the Chester, the toy store manager.
I talk to the bosses that be and they're
very supportive of what I do here.
I come here to rehearsal.
And then go back and stay later.
I call this place the theatrical
love of my life.
It's -- yeah it's -- I love this place.
[ Singing ]